so do you think once they realize that
this is one of one of the failure cases
one of the things that people are
concerned about is governments banning
cryptocurrency well that's
china case right they they started
realizing this was a legitimate threat
to capital controls and to the
autocratic system that they've
constructed there and then suddenly
china has started to build its own
people's bank of china blockchain
and bitcoin is now the red-headed
stepchild they didn't really care too
much because it's great for corruption
you could have a capital control since
all the
like well-connected people there's oh
yeah bitcoin's bad but then they'd have
bitcoin of their own and they could use
it to send money around but now the
government's gotten very serious about
it they're
saying like okay we want to control and
dominate this whole thing and it's a
threat to our plan for the digital yuan
to become the world standard to displace
the dollar
but so the moment you have el salvador
and just more and more countries say
there will be a country in europe for
example right
that uh that accepts bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies
cardano the idea is to put a lot of
pressure on you
so there'll be like this kind of ripple
effect right that you'll be
and then the individual governments
won't be able to help and eventually
there'll be a superpower
like i don't know russia or the united
states and or
i don't know canada uh so do you see
that sort of an inevitable
uh trend where cryptocurrency takes over
the world as
a as a as a store of value and as a
method of
payments yeah probably i mean you can do
just so much more
with programmable financing transactions
in general have five properties you know
you have the asset that runs on the rail
that's what we always think about
and you can transact that you know and
then you have the identity
and you transact that either like one to
one one to many many to one or many to
many
and then you have metadata so that's the
story of the transactions like where did
it take place
these types of things and then you have
the contractual relationship so that's
the smart contract component and then
you embed that within regulation
so transactions always live within
jurisdictions this is relevant to the
conversation will digital currencies
take over
because those things are right now done
separately
in a very fragmented and fractured way
and they're not completely globalized
and so super expensive to hoist up this
entire system
and automate things like compliance it's
usually a huge part of every banks
balance sheet so when you look at the
concept of a digital currency you're
saying
all five of those things are
programmable and so they could be like
library driven you say oh i want to be
in compliance with the
eritrea okay pull up the air train
library now you are
it's built into the transaction
previously it's like go hire some
lawyers
and go figure out the entire code and
translate some things and
it's crazy um so the just the
orders of magnitude efficiency gains
that you get
and the increased liquidity you get and
the fact that you can now represent
all assets with a universal way that
financial stem cell
there's an inevitability to the victory
of our industry
the challenge is how do we deal with
this with the squabbling of superpowers
you know china wants to be the new world
standard america wants to preserve that
and the rest of the world is trying to
figure out how do we create something
that's a bit more fair and balanced
and so crypto comes in and it
potentially is uh both an ally and a
competitor to those desires because if
you do too much crypto
you need the nation state anymore if you
do too little crypto well you know
it's china or america you know so
where's that what's that sweet spot
you